bonjour paul thompson merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france habitation et comment est ce
que vous interprétez d'abord ses excuses
de boris johnson sur les fusillades qui
ont fait je le rappelle dit mort en 1971
en irlande du nord et pour lesquels la
justice a dénoncé justement le rôle de
l'armée britannique
je pense que c'était un acte juste et
compréhensible du chef du gouvernement
qu'elle boris johnson là il a eu
plusieurs enquêtes sur ces incidents et
effectivement ça dure et à peu près 50
ans pour apporter lumière sur le sur le
sujet donc je pense que c'était un
message adressé aux familles qui étaient
les destinataires direct de la lettre
signée pas besoin de sa main et à un
trajet directement aux familles et est
donc c'était politiquement significative
pour assumer une certaine responsabilité
vis-à-vis de ces personnes qui ont
souffert beaucoup et dans ce contexte
justement les britanniques le
gouvernement britannique veut aller plus
loin et est allé vers là nestea
justement pour tous les crimes commis
dans cette période dite de troubles qui
a duré je le rappelle jusqu'en 1998
jusqu'au fameux accords de paix du
vendredi saint
je pense que ce sont vous vous avez
reproché les deux choses et c'est
compréhensible
néanmoins je pense que ce sont deux
questions distinctes
il faut se rappelait qu il y a eu avec
ses troubles n'ont pas des nombreux
morceaux du 3 mai que vous avez indiquée
en irlande du nord mais en angleterre
aussi dire bien sûr il y a eu des
incidents en plein coeur de londres des
attaques
de la ra à oui je veux pas me cramer et
est donc le l'idée qu'il devrait y avoir
une amnistie est le résultat d'une
pléthore d'action justice contre contre
des militaires
c'est un peu comme si une âme avait
institué des actions de justice contre
des contre des militaires français qui
avait servi en algérie pendant la guerre
d'indépendance de l'algérie le fait
admettre de tels procès contre des
dépôts des particuliers est de nature à
prolonger
ddd des problèmes politiques et donc je
pense que ce sont des questions qui
concernent cerner les troubles comme
vous dites d'accord comme ça ça calme m
mais ce sont deux heures ce petit
rempart de le gouvernement britannique
veut mettre fin à des procès contre des
militaires qui mettant son trajet est
qui et qui ont servi dans des conditions
très difficiles
donc si je vous comprends bien parce que
dans ce ses excuses de boris johnson il
a reconnu enfin la justice a reconnu en
tout cas un usage disproportionné de la
force contre certains civils dont pour
où sa responsabilité les davantage
politique
non ce que je sais que je sais de dire
ce que il ya une dimension politique
patience et le premier ministre et il a
une responsabilité en tant que tel en
verre tous les citoyens britanniques et
tout le monde en iran ou non des
catholiques les protestants et il essaie
une attaque justice de ce afin de
reconnaître le
[Musique]
qu' il y avait des fautes commises il
dit dans sa lettre d'ailleurs qu'il
accepte les conclusions de cette enquête
qui ont été rendues récemment et que les
lélés les forces de l'ordre non ports et
leurs mais n'a pas n'a pas été
impeccable dans son action mais il ne
dit pas que des personnes devraient être
il ne va pas de loin et la question de
l'anesthésiant par ailleurs à cause de
pressions en angleterre parce que
beaucoup de gens l'angleterre sont
choqués que il y a des des actions de
justice contre des militaires à titre
individuel et kantari que et ces
troubles ont correspondu un véritable de
situation de guerre civile
il est considéré que c'était inapproprié
que des militaires qui étaient engagés
soit soient traînés devant les tribunaux
des décennies après alors qu'ils ont se
sont exposés à de grands dangers
beaucoup de leurs camarades sont morts
tony blair qui a été premier ministre à
la signature des accords de paix en 1998
prône plutôt pour une commission
réconciliation une commission vérité et
réconciliation
est ce que est ce que c'est votre avis
est ce qu'il vaut mieux aller vers cette
solution comme l'a fait d'ailleurs
l'afrique du sud au monde l'apartheid
même si les deux événements sont
évidemment incomparables ça ne me paraît
pas une mauvaise idée je parle à titre
personnel je ne sais pas quelle est la
réaction de beauce tiendra de sumer l'as
activement je pense qu'une approche
constructive et qui
qui s'efforce de ramener les gens
ensemble vers une voie d'apaisement
avait tourné vers l'avenir la leur
pardon c'est important ça tombe
évidemment cette remise sur la table de
ce projet de loi tombe au moment où il
ya des tensions à cause du breakbeat
entre l'irlande et la grande-bretagne
vous pensez que c'est le bon moment
justement de tourner la page
enfin tourner la page quand il pas dans
le sens de doubler ce qui ce qui s'est
passé mais oui je pense que cet anti
clément important aujourd'hui votre
caisse 80,2 de mettre l'accent sur le
positif et faire en sorte que les gens
travaillent ensemble le président est
quelque chose de compliqué qui apporte
ses propres complications avec ce
protocole sur le long du nantais qui
perturbe le commerce et qui aussi
symboliquement inquiétant pour les aider
ceux qui sont très attachés à la
continuité de la rando dans le royaume
uni donc oui vous avez raison il est
particulièrement important aujourd'hui
d'avoir de vrais pour une bonne
communication une bonne communion même
je dirais entre les différentes
communautés han han et ils ont dit non
et cela demande du temps du courage
aussi une mentalité tourné vers l'avenir
des différents responsables à londres à
belfast à dublin et à l'intérieur du
land du nord entre les communautés
catholiques et protestants et des grands
groupements merci beaucoup paul thompson
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france